[Musik]
wenn ich darüber sprechen würde wenn ich
das täte was würde ich ihnen erzählen
wir reden über das shape worte das ist
der neue film eines der führenden
regisseuren fantastischen kino der mann
heißt gamer tode hat einerseits so zarte
glasbläser ein wie pans labyrinth
gedreht und andererseits solche
dampframme pacific rim und der film über
den witz reden heißt shape of water hat
die filmfestspiele von venedig gewonnen
hat einen golden globe ein gesagt und
ist für 13 oscars und das shape of water
ist die glitschig den märchen romanze
die es je gegeben hat also es geht um
ein mauerblümchen stumme aber nicht
taube frau die ich sex mit einem
menschenähnlichen fisch monster hat das
funktioniert als poesie das funktioniert
als liebesgeschichte das funktioniert
als fantastischer film das funktioniert
also als horrorfilm als fantasy film und
sogar ein bisschen als science fiction
[Musik]
die frau esposito gespielt von der
unfassbar guten sally hawkins die eine
ungeheure energie entfaltet diesen film
weil sie einfach mehr für sich will als
was man so bekommt in liebesgeschichten
und klemmt sich ganz schön dahinter dass
sie das auch kriegt inklusive die
vereinigten staaten von amerika zum
zeitpunkt des kalten krieges in riesige
gefahr bringen und sich mit den russen
ein lassen und dann doch nicht
also da kennt sie nicht der zweite grund
warum es funktioniert ist dieses monster
monster ist außerdem ein gott und es
wird ja tatsächlich höchste zeit dass
frauen anspruchsvoll genug werden dass
sie wieder so denken wie in der antike
also vor der langen christlichen und
modernen pause wo es ganz normal war
das interessante frauen sich natürlich
mindestens mit göttern einlassen es
dürfte das sensibelste objekt sein dass
die bestattung in dieser einrichtung
der dritte grund ob es funktioniert ist
dass die person die am meisten dagegen
hat und dagegen tut dass diese
liebesgeschichte zu sich kommt denn man
braucht natürlich ein hindernis in den
weg interessant sein soll
der unfassbare michael shannon ist die
fieseste [ __ ] die seit langem durch
kino gelaufen ist
herrlich ist wie immer weniger ist klar
last
wer soll da reingehen ich würde sagen
alle menschen die schon mal verliebt
fahren alle menschen die vorhaben
irgendwann verliebt zu sein oder alle
menschen die sich total der folge sind
sich zu verlieben
weil für die alle ist was drin
[Musik]